you know that is one of the highest
possible motivations you can have you
look down at your children and you say
it stops here the family curse stops
here
we went bankrupt we lost everything I
had a brand new baby and a toddler and I
had this visceral spiritual reaction
never again it stops here
this branch of rameses this branch in
the tree will have no more debt I will
teach them we will make so much money
and we will never borrow again and we
didn't and we have never again never
again no more I'm done when you have
that moment you change your family tree
when you have that moment you can change
everything and sometimes it's just you
know there's so much pain and stress in
your life sometimes there's stuff going
on I mean sometimes you just look at it
and you go I don't live like this we
make too much money to be this problem
but sometimes you look down in those
little eyes or that toddler that baby
that 14-year old I don't care and you
say never again we're changing this
we're changing this thing let's brown
the great motivator he says people
change their lives when they finally say
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
I've had when you have that I've had it
moment it changes everything
David how you get out of debt you have
your I've had it moment the rest of it
will work itself out I'm not sure I
agree with Dave Ramsey about the debt
snowball I don't give it
what you agree with I really don't I am
not motivated by what you think at all
but I'll tell you this
well you agree with my methodologies or
not there's one way people get out of
debt they finally say I've had it this
is not an intellectual problem if it was
an intellectual problem you would find
an intellectual solution it's not an
academic problem if there was an
academic problem you'd find an academic
solution this is an emotional spiritual
visual
visceral experience and until you feel
it in your bones I've then you've had it
then it's going to change because that's
the moment you don't care what someone
else thinks you're whining carping
mother-in-law who's got an opinion about
your credit score you suddenly don't
care what she thinks about your debt
because you've had it your friend who
looks down their nose at you because
they are so supposedly sophisticated
with money and they have none
you suddenly don't care what they think
when you say I've had it you don't care
what some broke journalism student with
a hundred and ten thousand dollars in
student loan debt writing a bad article
on Motley Fool or CNN money about money
you suddenly don't care what they think
because you've had it I'm getting out
this is the last one in this family tree
we're changing this thing the curse
stops here the chains come off here
that's when you change your life it's
not when you academically or no do grams
is a snake oil salesman I don't give a
crap what you think about me when you've
had your moment your I've had it moment
that's when you will change my life is
pretty good I don't need to change it
this is the Dave Ramsey chef